hello everyone and welcome to the
quarterfinals of the indian qualifier
where
two of the top plays gentlemen will uh
go into the champions chess store and
here we have a game between pragnanda
and the bhaskaran adiban
and three games have already been played
the first two games ended in a draw and
audiban
won the third game so now prague with
the white pieces has to win
at the fourth tie breaks uh this is a
rapid game so if he
manages to force tybury's then we go
into uh two blitz games like we've
already seen that in the previous game
that we've shown so here
uh let's see how prague does with the
white pieces and can he
force tie breaks so prague with the
white pieces opens
with d4 we have knight to f6
c for g6 knight to c3 and d5
and as you you can see the quote above
the board alibaba says b3
uh as he won the previous game by using
his b3 nimzo larson idea
as you all know he he did a course on
the opening uncheckable
uh so he also employs it now but this is
what i find very interesting now that a
lot of
strong grandmasters are also making
chessable courses
uh that uh they kind of maybe feel
obligated to use them and then maybe
it's easier to prepare for them
but it seems seems like it's not it's a
very
sharp opening and uh you know it's it's
a cool game it's not
as nice as this one so i decided to show
this one but do check it out if you
manage i will even put a link to it in
the description below
uh so you can check it out so here we
have d5 uh
going for the groomfield defense we have
c captures knight captures
and e4 now so just the the main line of
the exchange variation kicking
back the knight or forcing black to
capture knight captures on c3b captures
and
bishop to g7 so all very standard stuff
we have knight to f3
c5 now striking in the center and the
bishop to e3
white continues development we have
bishop to g4 and now
uh queen to a for check unpinning uh
with
with check so knight to d7 and now this
position has been reached many times and
the unknown moves here are knight to e5
and also bishop to e2 you do not want to
allow
bishop captures on f3 or but even you
can in a lot of lines
this has been allowed uh but here we
have rook to d1 by program
and it is as of move tended we have a
completely new game so let's see how
audiban deals with this he simply
castles the safety now the knight can
move
uh we bishop the e2 and now he trades in
the center once we have captures
captures and
knight to f6 and if you look at the
position now
uh it's uh it's uh well it's a normal
position
there's nothing wrong with the white's
position white usually will have this
very nice center here
black has a two to one advantage on the
queen side so if it gets to that it
could be
uh advantageous but as you can see both
players still having the bishop
pair so you know it can really go either
way and
uh you can't really castle uh because
the e4 pawn is hanging so you have to
deal with that
and if you advance the e pawn then some
like knight d5 attacks the bishop on e3
and you again i can't really castle
because there's also knight
to c3 attacking the rook and the bishop
and the queen so you have to deal with
this so instead we have d5
now the queen guards the e4 pawn and now
uh
well prague says okay my position is now
just better i'm just gonna
slow play this wait for a mistake on
your part and maybe i can even out to
the match but
uh ariban says nope and he plays b5
and p b5 is a very uh aggressive idea
of course the idea is you want to get
rid of the queen defending the e4 pawn
if this happens then black is just
better
uh you're you've just grabbed white's
very strong central pawn in the euro
again threatening knight to c3 so
white still cannot castle uh definitely
not something uh to look for so instead
we have bishop captures and b5 again
this uh that doesn't have to be captured
you could play something like queen to
b4
uh but uh prague says oh okay i don't
see
you having anything here so let's see
where's the
uh compensation for the sacrifice pawn
and here you could
go for knight captures uh on e4 right
away for example queen captures an e4
and then
let's say you trade the bishop for
knight here captures captures
and then you will win back the bishop
with queen to a5 check for example king
f1 queen captures and b5 with
check and then the game continues but
yeah even though you've messed up uh
white's king side it's not really a lot
the king will be
very safe on g2 you can bring the rooks
into the game and you have a very nice
d5 pawn here so
not much to to look for uh so instead
after bishop captures on b5 we have rook
to b8 now
uh putting pressure on the bishop so for
the moment you cannot go phone grabbing
but you could capture uh with with this
bishop but still
then you again have to worry about
knight captures on e4 queen day five
check and so on
so here prague just goes bishop to c6
and he says okay now
my position is just better what is the
compensation
behind this pawn sacrifice uh well
adiban goes
knight to h5 and again what do you play
here you always have to
take a take into account that this
bishop captures an f3 whether it's okay
to capture this or not and then uh
your king side will get all messed up
but
there's not there's not much you can do
about this you don't have a
bishop here to bring back to e2 you
cannot bring the queen back
uh you cannot move the knight otherwise
bishop captures rook on d1 so you have
to
do something and here uh prague just
bravely captures the pawn
uh with queen captures on a7 so grabbing
yet another pawn
uh and now adiban is down two points and
he has to
well he has to show what's uh what his
plan is
so he captures an f3 first g captures
and now just
slow plays queen to d6 so what's what's
happening here
uh well he's saying that okay now uh you
will not be all that safe here
on the king side if you castle king side
i can easily bring my queen into the
game the bishop can come to e5 could be
very strong
the knight can later come to f4 i can
maybe use my rooks along the b
file and it could be could be very
dangerous and
still and even just castles and bishop
to e5 will put a lot of pressure on
blacks uh
on white's king's side so instead we
have queen to d7
now uh prague was up two pawns you have
to uh
exchange queens and hopefully win the
game so queen to
f6 and now uh you would very much like
to start pushing your past pawn here
your even some of the squares are
already nicely nicely protected by the
bishops
but the problem is queen captures an f3
so prague first half's the
defend against this queen to g4 is
played and
now comes queen to c3 with check
so what do you play here uh you have to
either block this or
move the king king to f1 was played
there's nothing wrong with bishop to d2
uh
prague just prefers king to f1 but now
comes
f5 and this is just a crazy crazy
position it's interesting
that adamant chose such a funky line
even though he's leading the match and
he just you know sacrificed two pawns
out of the opening and now
uh is going for the attack but if it
works
i mean why not so he captures on f5 uh
and now
not recapturing but rather rook to b4
first bringing the rook into the game
with tempo
we have queen to g5 and now now comes
bishop to f6 and the queen doesn't have
all that many squares uh you could go uh
for example to h6 then
maybe bishop to g7 then if we go back
then black has to figure out a different
way how to play this uh but prague
immediately brings the queen back he
immediately brings the queen back to g1
and now now there's a problem uh here
bishop to d4 by adiban a very strong
idea is also king the h8 but this is a
rapid game you you don't always have
time to find
uh all the intricacies of the position
but here king the h8 uh with
rook coming to the g file is just insane
for example if you capture on g6
queen to c2 can be played attacking the
rook and now after you move the rook
queen d3 check and now you force the
king away if the rogue blocks then you
can just win the game with rook to b1 or
if the king goes here
now we just go let's say queen captures
with checking if one queen back to d3
would
check and if king two king to g2 then we
just deliver rook to ga to check
and this is now over so instead after
king the g1
uh sorry queen to g1 we have bishop to
d4
the other move that adiban found uh and
now comes
rook captures on d4 uh maybe
a different uh approach could have been
queen to g5 but then we just go back
bishop to f6 bishop to g7
and then we look for for other ideas
like bringing the knight to f4 and so on
uh but here we have rook capture sunday
for right away we have rook captures on
d4
and only now queen to g5 uh if you go
for this captures uh you could also try
this captures captures but this is just
unplayable for white this is just uh
look at this rook this is never coming
into the game the queen is really
terrible here and it's uh
it's really no way no way to play this
uh so instead uh queen to g5 was played
now white white queen is uh a much
better place
but now there's a problem so feel free
to pause the video and
win the game for adamant in the quickest
way possible while i give you a couple
of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on uh
playing uh either rook captures on f5
this
is possible but this is the slow way to
do it and for those of you who found
knights to f4
that's the good stuff you always have to
look for knight to f4 remember but fenik
vs style game six of their first match
knight to f4 you always have to look for
knight to f4 and good things will happen
so here knight to f4 and there is no uh
defense here for
for prague the e2 and g2 squares have
been covered
uh rook to d1 will just end the game on
the spot so you have to capture that
that there's no way around that uh
bishop captures an f4 was played
but now uh the f3 pawn is hanging so
queen captures on f3
now with a double attack on the bishop
and also attacking the rook
that would fall with check so what do
you play here and also there's just the
threat of rook to d1 checkmate
i mean how do you prevent all of these
threats uh here
uh prague tried uh bishop to d2 now okay
the bishop is defended you cannot
capture it or deliver checkmate but here
you can pretty much play anything and
it's still completely winning you could
grab the rook although this is dragging
the game on
uh adiman founded the quickest way to
win he played rook to b8 and he was in
this position on move 27
uh yes only 27 moves were played even
though it uh you know
looked more uh because we showed a lot
of sidelines
uh but rook to b8 and he was in this
position on move 27 that uh prague nanda
resigned to the game
as there is nothing more to be done here
so
the threat of rook to b1 is simply too
great and there is no stopping this you
could try bishop e1 for example
uh we still just play rogue b1 now the
threat is very clear for example you
capture on g6 we're just gonna capture
on e1
king captures and now let's say rook to
d1 checkmate so
obviously not not going to be played out
that way
and if you try anything else let's say
bishop to a4 to guard that
d1 square to prevent this line then we
just go rook to e4 and again
there is no no no way to prevent this
rook captures is coming and that's it
so uh prague sawdust after rook to b8 he
resigned the game
and with it uh the opportunity to join
uh the
the uh the big guys in the champions
chester because he is now out of the
competition and adiban uh you know
uh goes uh into the uh upper parts of
the competition
so audiban won uh both game three and
game four and like i said he won game
three with his very nice b3 move uh that
you can check in the description below
also i will put a link to that
so congratulations to adiman taflak for
prague uh but you know only only uh
you know in highlander they say there
can be only one but in this tournament
there can be only two uh so that's uh
the game hope you guys enjoyed it uh
and that it improved your weekend at
least a little bit
uh i would like to thank aditya parashar
hattie
uh kashid sharma simon johansson william
gould and mayuresh modak for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and i
will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the morphe
saga checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world
so thank you i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day